an important task in machine learning is
prediction given some information
summarizing an independent variable x
for example the height of a person
predict the value of another dependent
variable y like their weight usually we
have a training data set that is a table
that contains values for both x and y
that we want to use to infer what the
function g should be we can then use
that learned function g to predict the
values y for new values of x not seen in
training finding the right function g is
called regression and the easiest way to
do this is to assume that this function
g is a linear function hence the name
linear regression here alpha is the
slope of this line and beta is the
intercept the simplicity of linear
regression makes it really attractive
we're only dealing with linear functions
here so no complicated neural networks
involved if you are faced with a
prediction problem linear regression
should really be the first thing that
you try to do linear regression we just
need to pick the alpha and beta that
makes this line fit the data as much as
possible one way to quantify the fit of
a line to a bunch of data points is to
consider where the point in the training
data set is and where it should be
according to this line
take the square of the difference and
then take the sum over all data points
to find the alpha and beta that make
this quantity as small as possible let's
take the gradient
set it to zero and solve for alpha and
beta congratulations you have just
solved a prediction machine learning
problem from scratch if now you want to
predict the weight of a new person you
just plug their height into this formula
in practice you don't have to do this
derivation by hand if you feel more
sophisticated you can fire up python
import psychic learn declare a linear
regression model and feed it to training
data and call the fit function to get
predictions you can just use the
function predict in addition to being
simple and tractable
linear regression is also very
extensible for example you can easily
adapt linear regression to fit a model
with more than just one variable as
input
in the same vein if you are not
satisfied with the linear relationship
you can augment your data with nonlinear
features another compelling aspect of
linear regression is the fact that we
can interpret the coefficients that we
get
for example if the slope is positive x
and y move in the same direction and if
the slope is negative they move in
opposite directions
good luck trying to find a meaningful
interpretation of the weights of a
neural network this was linear
regression in two minutes if you like
the video please make sure to like and
subscribe and see you next time